battlefield 2042 had a strong showing at
e3 this year with call of duty's plan
notably absent maybe we'll hear more
about vanguard later this summer
it really looks like battlefield is
winning right now in this video we're
gonna take a look at what's going well
for battlefield 2042 and call of duty
and what could spell disaster for either
game like over monetization and not
getting out of that yearly cycle
if you're looking forward to shooters
this year like we are make sure to give
us the old thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel
there should be so much more to talk
about in july let's get to it
why battlefield 2042 is winning right
now battlefield 2042 showed off some
pretty amazing stuff at e3 with more to
come at ea play live july 22nd
it has some of the largest purpose-built
maps in battlefield history a focus on
revamped conquest 128 players
tons of eco combat tornadoes seasons
with all the maps included for all
players
bots near future gadgets and a revamped
class system it's a game with a lot of
tailwinds pushing it forward people are
super ready for a modern battlefield
title we haven't had one since the final
stand dlc
in 2014 how crazy is that there's a huge
untapped group of battlefield fans who
loved modern warfare but were turned off
by cold war's more classic arcade feel
they were also alienated by the complete
cold war takeover of warzone basically
all the stars are lining up for an
audience that is ready and looking for
exactly what 2042 has to offer
but don't count call of duty out yet go
in dark
from a battlefield fans perspective
modern warfare 2019
was something special and if it had
continued for another year could have
kept eating battlefield's lunch with its
larger groundwater mode and warzone
rumble 50v 50. even though cold war took
the game in a direction that lost a
portion of this milsim leaning fan base
it's hard to ignore the fact that
battlefield is still gonna have to fill
some pretty big expectations set by
modern warfare in terms of
quality weapon handling pacing modes gun
customization and that amazing
moment-to-moment feel that call of duty
typically brings
battlefield also seems to be following
in the footsteps of modern warfare's
operators and some of the battle royale
inspired modes that warzone has already
tried the bar has been set pretty high
with vehicle royale
kingslayer haunting of her dance just so
many good ones
then there's also plunder which has
always had respawns another massive
influence battlefield might be taken
from warzone is how to tell a story
without a campaign
it involves seasonal cutscenes events
and challenges and warzone is kind of
ahead on that keep in mind call of duty
has had years of experience with this
type of storytelling having started back
with black ops 4 which
like 2042 had no campaign and also had
specialists with unique gadgets and
abilities
storytelling in warzone is not perfect
but it's getting there
also to consider it warzone will
probably start teasing the rumored
vanguard game in the near future which
is supposed to come out this year there
are some promising but unconfirmed
rumors around this game
cold war's integration into war zones
seemed very reactive and a bit scattered
but vanguard has a chance to come out of
the gate swinging with our warzone plan
they might even introduce an entirely
new map finally warzone's gunmeta is
generally in a great place right now
that's no small feat to keep that many
weapons balanced in the game there are
tons of viable loadouts and that can
keep things fresh
oh and the most important thing warzone
is free
and it's standalone all right so
battlefield 2042 has some big shoes to
fill
and it looks great but here's where it
could stumble dice has lost their player
base before when audiences felt the game
had become too focused on cosmetics and
micro transactions
and they really need to go out of their
way to win that trust back so far the
results are
mixed when developers speak about the
game their passion really shines through
and everything feels like it's in good
hands of people who are genuinely
excited about the battlefield sandbox
and what makes a great battlefield game
then you go to the website and think
about the business side of things some
areas of concern
are having to pay for a tiered launch
october 22nd for most
but october 15th if you're willing to
pay more like 99
yikes the use of the word premium which
when first out in a presentation maybe
kind of black out for a minute the
battle pass
system has two tiers the free tier and
the premium tier
but when i came to realize it just meant
a tiered battle pass system
which is kind of standard these days
premium the word
does not have a positive association in
the community and as one of the probably
few people who bought battlefield games
on multiple platforms and then was
forced to repurchase premium over and
over again i feel kind of
punished for my loyalty so even using
the word premium will arrest suspicion
and i recommend they bury it and
speaking of suspicion the new specialist
system can be seen as an exciting take
on classes but also a way to sell more
cosmetics in the way that modern warfare
did there's nothing inherently wrong
with that
i personally loved and purchased a few
modern warfare and warzone skins but if
people see the specialist
as having been added to the game just to
get rid of the assault engineer support
and recon system for monetary gain
they might not respond well to it don't
underestimate the kind of negative
enthusiasm that gamers can muster for ea
published titles
and what that did to battlefield 5 and
star wars battlefront 2. i personally
don't want that to happen to battlefield
2042 it's a game that i'm really excited
and looking forward to
just be aware that that distrust exists
for some people and you need to steer
way clear of it
the other thing is there's gonna be four
specialists added in the first few
seasons but we're not sure yet if
they're gonna be in the free and premium
tiers of the battle pass call of duty
locks some of their operators behind a
paywall but unlike call of duty
specialists in battlefield 2042 will
come with a unique gadget and ability
that could give them an unfair advantage
if not properly balanced we're hoping
that like
maps operators are included with each
battle pass for the free tiers
and maybe like call of duty paying more
just jumps you ahead in the battle pass
speaking of a battle pass can dice pull
off a not battle royale game there were
a number of issues with battlefield 5's
firestorm mode
the top of which was it sat behind a
full price game purchase which
battlefield 2042
might very well do again in all fairness
it took call of duty
two tries to get it right since blackout
4's blackout mode
was just an ok ish attempt at launch we
listed some good modes earlier that
warzone has tried when they strayed away
from pure battle royale and dice is
plenty to do something similar hazard
zone has been described as a squad based
mode that builds tension over time
where loadouts matter also the word
hazard implies areas of the map being
cut off which sounds very battle right
out we're gonna have to see where it
goes
there have been good and bad takes on
getting away from battle royale games
cold war's dirty bomb in particular was
memorably bad in my opinion but again
there's been other great attempts
through warzone so let's wait and see
hazard zone could be awesome and it's
supposed to be playable before launch
finally battlefield really needs to nail
the basics battlefields never really
felt as clean or sublime as call of duty
moment to moment
it's always had a larger sandbox at the
expense of clunky controls less fluid
movement issues with hit registration or
server lag
and often sported a confusing unlock
tree like last night i was playing
battlefield 4 and opened up a gold
battle pack and got an epic
goat emblem shape what
we can't wait to get our hands on alphas
and betas for battlefield 2042 to see
how this all has developed the gameplay
we did see in trailers looked very crisp
and now there's a whole sub engine in
frostbite for vehicle physics so i'm
personally hopeful dice will get the
basics down this time
and the game will feel good we can
already see some improvements from over
the years like diversified hit markers
and in the long run as a battlefield fan
i do prefer the freedom of a sandbox to
more polished experiences if i had to
pick one or the other
okay so those are the pitfalls that
battlefield has to not fall into this
year
what are the things that could knock out
call of duty as well after such an
amazing year of modern warfare 2019
a lot of goodwill was lost by the
rollout of cold war and the takeover of
war zone call of duty's yearly cycle
ground on even though there was a huge
appetite for modern warfare to keep
going
cold war feels far less popular and if
you go to the comments around vanguard
rumors
a lot of people are saying they don't
want a world war ii game if that's what
vanguard winds up being
even worse once a new call of duty game
is released with warzone there's just no
going back
warzone has continued to give the
perception that it's erasing modern
warfare's gritty take and has gone in a
very silly arcade direction there's been
a nail gun dominating the meta lately
we've gone
cod mobile levels of silly pretty fast
and that does have its own large
audience it's just not the same audience
that came from modern warfare and
potentially for battlefield it feels
like warzone made a huge blunder by
adding in all the cold war weapons and
setting up this expectation
of each new call of duty game doing the
same that's gotta be a nightmare for
balance
and that means the guns on the ground
don't match the call of duty game that
you love
so much as whatever call of duty game
activision's trying to push you to buy
at that time
in stark contrast think of how other top
battle royale games have handled weapons
fortnite vaults and unvaults them to
keep the list manageable and so does
apex weapons are rolled out seasonally
or on occasion for each game but
generally players know the meta and what
to expect when they play as opposed to
what happens each time a new call of
duty title takes over warzone and then
screams to fans of the previous game
this isn't your war zone anymore tying
warzone to games too closely means that
if people don't like
that game at that time they like warzone
a lot less for example as a huge modern
warfare fan
i look at the operators and weapons on
the ground right now in warzone and
there's just no connection to it and i
further don't have an investment because
i don't want to go grind guns in cold
war
even now if you buy modern warfare you
get pushed to buy a battle pass that has
nothing to do with modern warfare they
really need these battle passes to give
rewards across
all the call of duty games integrated
into warzone so we're just gonna have to
see if vanguard has something special to
offer
specifically if the rumor is true that
it's going to add a new larger warzone
map
and we're also gonna have to see what
kind of cool in-game events might be
leading up to it
but they've kind of worn out the nuke
story at this stage so it needs to be
something different
and that's about where we're at right
now a potentially great battlefield on
the horizon
a dissolution to modern warfare audience
who are ready to play and two large
developers duking it out
dice who needs to stick the landing and
avoid appearing to cater to cosmetics
and microtransactions too much
and sledgehammer stuck in activision's
yearly cycle barreling forward and
needing to convince shooter fans that
they want world war ii in their lives
again
to be fair again this game setting is
not confirmed yet regardless
it's a pretty exciting time to be a
gamer we're expecting to learn a lot
more about battlefield 2042 on july 22nd
followed by alphas and betas and
hopefully more announcements about
vanguard later this summer
so make sure to head on over to
gamestop's youtube page and give us a
thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and we'll let
you know as things happen
alright thanks for watching
[Music]
you